[Music]
damn
what the [ __ ] in there yeah some Drano
or some [ __ ] and too far nears to faster
in Drano leaves a bitter Bartok clarin
may JK fan full-time that's right son
who need the job
CNN fires Kathy Griffin's you
represented ocean after posting a photo
with president from steak bloody severed
head Wow Wow I saw this picture it's
crazy is that crazy cuz watch it's
pretty crazy I want to see how crazy is
crazy
show us the cool right now show you the
crazy in a second so because you were
like well see you then
so the reason why Kathy Griffin was
fired by CNN is because for the past 10
consecutive years she has hosted along
with Anderson Cooper
the New York Times Square New Year's Eve
live oh that were native from I see so
she won't be saying happy new years
never light her yeah I mean you know my
gosh yeah I never understood her joke
well she Kathy Griffin is like one of
those like female comics that I think a
lot of women respect because she was
very edgy Albertan for know it's in
general she's still very edgy you know I
don't want us all hang out like there's
a lot of people out there that a
respected in that case I mean I think a
lot of people don't get in and they
don't like it as much but at the same
time she was a boundary pusher yeah she
was a woman and power yeah I don't get a
I never listened to her jokes I just
find her very annoying you enjoy tech
you women got a bond together I know man
oh you're gonna [ __ ] take over two
dudes how you guys focus on the negative
so much no to focus on the positive
combining forces yeah just because she's
a ginger you hater yup can't believe you
said I thought y'all were we're all
about female right you can't stutter and
try to make a profound statement you
thanks Ken yes I
hahaha all right so I'm going to show
you guys a video clip and it's her like
with the head and then after this clip
is going to be her apology okay oh my
god that is [ __ ] graphic hey
everybody it's me Cathy Brisco she's not
sincerely apologize I am just now seeing
the reaction of these images I'm a comic
I crossed the line I move the line then
I cross it I went way too far the image
is too disturbing
I understand how offends people it
wasn't funny I get it
I've made a lot of mistakes in my career
I will continue I asked your forgiveness
taking down the image going to ask the
photographer to take down the image and
I beg for your forgiveness I went too
far
I made a mistake and I was wrong we may
need to back each other up her apology
was go really sincere it was like I
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] up and I [ __ ] up
that's how [ __ ] United should have
been it anything cuz I was on Twitter
and you know there are people who I'll
be at all contexts were saying like you
should stand your ground comedy is
comedy but at the same time you know
best is still the President of the
United States you know what I mean and
that was extremely graphic kind of rain
also too like I don't know what's funny
about it
like what's the funny in it yeah what
was the funny about it I would take it
as an art piece but I wouldn't take it
as a comedy thing he has a threat yeah
I'm surprised like the FBI didn't come
[ __ ] knocking on a door [ __ ] a
[ __ ] up well the Secret Service has
announces like she should expect a knock
on her door it looks like a terrorist
threat he does look like a chance
they're saying like no matter who says
what like if there's a threat against
the president they're going to take it
serious I just want to know what the
comedy was behind
did you ever explain herself so she
worked with Tyler Shields so have you
guys heard of him he's a pretty famous
photographer No so Tyler Shields is the
one I created this image and like that
video clip and so they both release the
photos the exact same time and when she
released her photo she captioned it
quote I captioned this there was blood
coming out of this
I love comics coming out of his wherever
that was her caption so I guess like
poking fun at what Trump has said in the
past about megyn kelly during the
presidential primary season on my couch
you know she was just making fun of her
like oh she's a woman like who knows
where blood comes out of so then I guess
that was the whole Joe
but it's so niche and so like not not
everyone would understand it unless you
understand that incident she was it was
morbid oh yeah extremely morbid and like
I said still the President of the United
States like you have to realize - let's
say well unless present us saying
somebody did a Barack Obama you know
what I mean you not be taking that [ __ ]
lightly at all yes I'm going to show you
guys some tweet so the first one is
Trump
he says Kathy Griffin should be ashamed
of herself my children especially my 11
year old son Barron are having a hard
time with it sick should the [ __ ] want
to go that Blitzer grab her in the [ __ ]
CNN has terminated our agreement with
Kathy Griffin to appear on our New
Year's Eve program next one have
Anderson Cooper tweeting for the record
I am appalled by the photo shoot Kathy
Griffin - pardon it is clearly
discussing and completely inappropriate
damnation
maybe I'm insensitive or something but I
don't understand what was disgusting
about it I just looked so real so
already it's our nation's leader right
whether you like it or not he's he's you
know the face of the u.s. unfortunately
and then she does that and it just looks
so real it's so graphic and but I find
it obvious that Donald Trump is alive in
the night it's registered but that
doesn't doesn't matter it could you
would say well our presence of live
somebody could say kill the president
you know is the same thing so if people
get their lives tapped and people have
those two words together and the FBI
comes knocking on the door this is like
an actual graphic like I have a severed
head I think it's also insensitive on
the part that um there have been a lot
of Isis killings that would beheadings
like that and the fact that like
it's a sensitive image right now I see
our leader in the combination of
something that we relate to as a
terrorist act yeah it's been a good
sight to see
I think cuz for me it's like that image
is obviously fake it's different if it
was like a cow head that was Rihanna's
guts and blood so I think for me I'm
like well that's obviously a movie
makeup and wax and whatever so to logic
you're a robot that's a robot you know
what she should have done it would have
been so different and she just got
Donald Trump's head and [ __ ] rubbed
it on her vagina that's way better that
would have been probably easier to sell
yeah she just should have just been like
good it might be right and even Chelsea
Clinton tweeted out what is it this is
vile and wrong and is never funny to
joke about killing a president and then
Donald Trump jr. tweeted disgusting but
not surprising this is the left today
they consider this acceptable imagine a
conservative did this to Obama as a
POTUS but they did yeah so then business
is the best we was going around a lot so
this GOP called Obama mannequins hanging
free speech but apparently Kathy Griffin
doesn't get that right so it's just like
putting in furnace I'm not saying that
this is right in any way but there's
educate you got argument because I
remember um what's it called
there was this whole ordeal on the news
they were like burning like [ __ ]
Obama dolls and [ __ ] like lighting it on
fire so you know I don't know about that
argument working there yeah well he got
him like that this [ __ ] was [ __ ]
mayhem dude yup there were also people
saying like you know they've been saying
a lot of backing just saying a lot of
bad things about their bomb was already
like calling Michelle a gorilla and like
all this kind of stuff it's like no
matter who's president they're always
going to bash on the president is
stomping a celebrity does that make it I
guess so doesn't justify any of this
absolutely crazy with morbid mm-hmm and
then like Melania is just saying like
it's very disturbing and simply wrong I
always forget she sleeps English
all of us your copies Michelle now only
she still teaches miss Obama Singh
have you seen these funny ass clips of
like Trump trying to like be
affectionate towards Melania yeah she
slapped her hands like with Jackson
douchey straight-up does not like that
dude yeah unless those are like like you
know relationship wise but that's a lot
and in the public - yeah he's like this
don't touch me nobody touch me I would
not want him to touch me why he saw him
in Holland money doesn't motivate me
babe yes it does when you guys are
married though was that was that mean of
the children and she makes a choice so
that's what you're saying is someone
that wouldn't even marry the guy I heard
that very and 11 year old son apparently
he saw that image pop up on the news and
he cry he thought that his dad was like
something did actually what a dumbass
even though it's dad's like in the back
make of cereal you probably wasn't a lot
of guys like right behind me right here
fill your bar Kansa imagine seeing
images make sense oh yeah how does he
that's not who's your lover okay I give
him that he gets a salute yeah was he
the kid would be that kid during the
speech he just looked like you know the
acceptance speech yeah yeah yeah he was
that kid yeah that's was like so [ __ ]
and there was also people saying like
well this didn't happen to that
president will yes it did and it will
doesn't make it right no it doesn't
there's just a lot of that conversation
about this holes it just wasn't
publicized because that was the first
time I saw Obama mannequins and paper
mache that was being hanged yeah I had
never seen everybody I've never seen
those a big ordeal when he got elected
man it was all over
well I know a lot of people didn't like
that he was getting elected because
they're like especially the KKK you know
that there's like a very famous I mean
you could not even be what you could
look it up but there's like a picture of
him of a mannequin jeans burn like
actually was it was a big ordeal when we
were getting elected like people and I
think it also it's different when you
have just a random image versus like a
celebrity endorsement of let me know who
did it and the source I think it's a
little bit different than some of that
they just felt like [ __ ] chinks on the
wall like you know we know if we did it
yeah they're like nobodies
you're not important yeah but if Tom
Cruise did it oh [ __ ] what our crew is
why I think my fam are doing oh you mean
so much like this one right here they're
doing this like a duel at a church here
they have the best bonfires though I
love turn cars that's true if you need
help with a campfire or a barbecue just
hire some church they know how to
[ __ ] burn [ __ ] well we were burning
that a bottle man again alright then
we'll just rub two sticks together like
this and then they busted out the
[ __ ] guitar acoustic guitar and they
have espers hallelujah
did you guys enjoyed that episode of
just kitty news if you did please leave
a comment down below and share us your
thoughts and your feelings for more
episodes click right up here
you